Тетяна долучилася до добровольчого
батальйону Карпатська Січ 24 лютого нині
жінка Служить у різних місцях на
передовій видача єдиного комплекту
військової форми стала для
військовослужбовець неприємним сюрпризом
потім коли вже наш батальйон
легалізувався ввійшов до лав збройних
сил України
видають форму видають форму 58-го
розміру
форум чоловічі труси
XXL
берці видали 42-го розміру Потім
ну такі речі
термобілизну видали так само нині в
Українській армії служить понад 38 тисяч
жінок це одна з найбільших часток жінок
у збройних силах у світі однак
українські солдатки масово скаржаться на
відсутність форм з їхніми розмірами
жіночих засобів гігієни а також на
надважкі шоломи і бронежилети
і мені видають чоловічі труси
просто це
і думаєш Ну вже можна було б закупити Та
хоч ну
потурбуватись шкарпетки
зимові термобілизна тоже великого
розміру це не жіноча військова форма
вона не дуже зручна тим що вона не
ергономічна тут низька посадка і
насправді Там не дуже зручно носити
наприклад кобуру з пістолетом от
проверки взагалі ми вчора наприклад
зараз глянемо в чоловічу сорочку тому що
вона зручніше Але вона все одно велика
Маргарита рівчаченко вступила в Київську
тероборону в перший день
повномасштабного вторгнення Росії на
своїх чергуваннях жінка щоразу відчувала
незручність причинену військовою формою
піксельна просто я потім в ній тонула і
там перші місяці коли було холодно я
ходила Ну так як пампушка в мене форма
була більше ніж я автомат більше ніж я
ну тобто Це дуже незручно рухатися в
Великому одязі Тобто ти не можеш
нормально тримати зброю мені щось робити
якщо Тетяна ушивала видану форму то
Маргарита купила собі Другий вже її
розміру жінка оплачувала все з власної
кишені і зазначає що задоволення було не
з дешевих ну дивіться наприклад одні
штани коштують 2,500 грн там такківським
от кожна Футболка - це там 500-600 грн
плюс там ця футболка наприклад Polo
окремо ти там купуєш собі
білизну да більше спеціальні топи Які
наприклад втягують груди ну тобто я собі
купляла спеціальний спортивний топ тому
що бігати в бронежилеті і просто в
принципі займатися фізичними
навантаженнями ти не можеш коли в тебе
просто якась
кружевна красива білизна Як часто це
буває в Україні там де держава не може
впоратись самостійно на поміч приходять
волонтери проєкт примірять її берці
допомагає жінкам які служать з
військової формою взуттям засобами
гігієни про нежилетами і навіть шоломами
це форма та що ми кажемо унісекс так ту
що відмовляємо з Туреччиною Ось так от
вона виглядає це укс і це брюки
військову форму унісекс і берці
волонтери закуповують в Туреччині хоча у
планах відшивати одяг в Україні на думку
Ксенії у військкоматах немає комплектів
малих розмірів тому що держава не
очікувала такого різкого збільшення
кількості жінок в армії волонтерка
вірить що з часом Міноборони вирішить цю
проблему але вже зараз команда Ксенії
робить все щоб забезпечити якомога
більше жінок формою справа йде про
безпеку тому що великі штатні можуть
причепитися одна об іншу і солдатка так
на полі бою може буквально в прямому
сенсі впасти Тобто це може бути
небезпечно для неї це може бути
небезпечно для всього батальйону для
жінок на передовій волонтери також
закуповують шведські плити для
бронежилетів
видає плити мінімум 4,2 кг десь отака
його це найлегші тобто Зазвичай це 5-6
комусь можуть видати дійсно тобто 6
кілограм одна плита тобто Уявіть собі це
Їх дві це 12 кг а це ще
рюкзак-параметика наповнений не порожній
А це щоб аптечка ще казка і ти парамедик
і ти ще тягнеш чоловіка який важить
80-90 кг які теж би мені ціну Тобто це
супер важко і тому ця плита вона важить
2,9 кг але коли різниця навіть там в 4
кг або в 2 кг між вагою яка на тобі це
відчувається драганюк відзначає що
військова форма може бути ще кращою
пошитою за жіночими лекалами а не
унісекс однак на такі комплекти потрібен
час якого зараз у військових у зоні
бойових дій немає держава почала
працювати над військовою формою для
жінок у робочу групу увійшли
представники Міноборони дві волонтерські
ініціативи та уповноважена президента
України з питань безбар'єрності
депутатка Київради і волонтерка Ірина
никорак одна з учасниць робочої групи ми
власне почали аналізувати і навіть зараз
Продовжуємо Це робити світовий досвід
позаду мене І от власне тут у нас в
штабі дуже і багато екземплярів різних
форм які нам передавали зі Сполучених
Штатів Америки з Франції зараз очікуємо
ще з Канади з Ізраїлю Ми намагаємося
врахувати передовий світовий досвід як
Власне вони йшли тут за словами некорект
наразі тестування у польових умовах
проходять вже два прототипи жіночої
форми третій ще готується далі робоча
група чекатиме відгуків від
військовослужбовець нам потрібно її
протестувати і якщо процес тестування
пройде успішно Ми дійсно отримаємо
багато позитивних відгуків далі буде
етап затвердження самого лекала Як
тільки ми допрацюємо ці лекало ми їх
передаємо до Міністерства оборони і далі
вже буде прийматися рішення
про те чи можна адаптувати існуючу
уніформу чоловічу під жіночу
антропометрію з урахуванням різних
фіксаторів пом'якшуючи і так далі чи
буде розроблена польова форма
безпосередньо жіночих однак Ані
представники робочої групи Ані
Міністерство оборони не вказують
термінів коли жінки зможуть отримати від
держави адаптовану військову форму Тому
військовослужбовицям все ще доводиться
вирішувати питання своїми силами або за
допомогою волонтерів хоча за словами
волонтерки Ксенії драганюк іноді для
українських жінок поїхати на нульові
позиції легше ніж попросити щось
безкоштовно були випадки коли дівчонки
приходять сюди до нас в хаб і роблять
так
[музика]
дискомфорт попросити є у всіх є дівчонки
які пишуть є два тижні наважувалися
Можна вас попросити форму будь ласка Я
кажу треба Ми кажемо ви не просите
дивіться кажу ми з вами зараз
розділилися задля спільної мети ви на
фронті ми в тилу ви там працюєте Ми тут
працюємо тому ви не просите
[музика]